it's time for roses and Rosie I don't
have my blanket and we don't have Peter
Krause you guys what a finale I
literally can't find my Road blanket
that I usually hold up and it's just one
of many reasons that I was so distraught
tonight okay the Bachelorette finale was
Monday night and regional Lindsay had
told me that it would be emotional but I
did not realize how emotional it would
be oh my god so much to discuss
three-hour live finale for the first
time ever was it necessary I don't
really think so we just wanted to see
what happened you know so let's I don't
know it may be table that for next year
anything we needed to do that okay
Rachel looks great and things get pretty
rough so see the guys are backstage they
look great Peter without a tie hi Peter
so in the next basically week at this
point what if I'm not ready to say will
you air me okay so back to Rachel and
Peter in the fantasy suite because
that's where we were left off halfway
through their fantasy suite I've done
this before
a five-year relationship that I thought
was moving towards marriage that never
left the girlfriend/boyfriend stage so
rachel brings up this like apparent
five-year relationship she had where she
was told by this guy that marriage was
going to happen and then it never did
and how do I know that it'll leave that
girlfriend and boyfriend stage with
Peter it doesn't here this is is it just
me or is this like the first time that
we've heard about this relationship and
I remember her mentioning it but it
seems to be very traumatic that's why
I'm
overwhelmed with emotion so she's like
Peter that's why you know this is so
hard for me overwhelmed with emotion but
Peters like I don't want to let you go
and they're like let's use the fantasy
suite to talk to each other and they get
their penis you see computers like Oh
super cute this is super cute I like
Peter another reason for me to love you
you comments on the decor I love so they
have their fantasy suite we get a little
bit of shirtlessness but not enough we
never get enough and then Peters like
the feelings of doubts are still there
the feelings of doubt but I have have
started to fade they're not gone
but they've gently certainly how we see
where this is going to go downhill
everybody down hill even walking away
cute kind of messing you look like a
shocker back to Brian Brian's in a red
Henley that flaps open in the wind make
such interesting fashion choices and
Rachel is like so clearly thinking about
Peter this whole date you know Peter
messed with my mind and I'm struggling
friends like today was awkward it didn't
go the way I wanted to just I don't know
it's awkward because she's thinking
about Peter here's what was painful is
that throughout the episode it seemed to
me as a fan that Rachel had stronger
feelings for Peter but knew that Brian
had stronger feelings for her Peter
dropped a bomb on me am I the only one
who felt that way I don't want to feel
that way that's why I care about I wish
Rachel a ride with us I really do
that it was awkward Chris Harrison is
like Rachel what did it like to go from
an emotional rollercoaster with Peter a
very difficult date mm-hmm right into
Brian equally difficult
no it wasn't she knows exactly a Brian
feels about her so what is the struggle
with Brian it's not like she's down to
her final two and she doesn't know you
know which one she may be like has the
the more clear connection with Pete you
see the Stanfill that I was with Peter
and I just kind of was like you know
what am i doing it seems it's just like
this guy's not that into me and and this
guy this one guy Brian I don't really
have any problems with I can't figure
out what problems she has a friend she
she she doesn't seem to have any but
they ended up together so that's great
that's great oh I'm so stressed like
there's such a hard time gathering my
feelings right now because I'm about to
go fly to New York to interview Rachel
and Ryan check it out sweetie oh my gosh
am I wrong so by the way drink every
time Rachel rip my own hair is good more
go wrong
good more go wrong real are you oh yes
but to be back at the place that I've
been at before drink every time Rachel
brings up this relationship we're
hearing before the robot for the first
time and a drink every time Peter says
he doubts so well his feeling for Rachel
and you know your God breathe
debris notice she hasn't mentioned Eric
for like the whole first hour so we
talked about fire all of us feel thrill
this is the last rose ceremony we get a
shot of a tombstone that's pretty
foreboding and rachel is wearing like
literal armor because of what she's
going for you're never ready for the
Kasai and Eric and Peter and Brian are
there and Eric's frog and some cool
sneakers but by Eric I like Eric a lot
go are you happy I'm very happy how are
you he's on live and he was great he was
like Rachel I just took her heart is
good and I'm always gonna care about you
and like he looks really great with his
beard and so like great Eric great and I
know there's gonna be the bachelor but I
like Eric Peter is like Rachel wants me
to propose yeah pastor Eric is with
where were we
oh then Peter and Brian each have one
more date is this to the rumor format
it's all screwed up because there's
three days in the finale and it's good
lays live a very confused so please you
know drink every time it goes too far
now
so back to Peter and Rachel they have
one more date and oh no Brian and Peter
Brian and you have a drink I screwed it
up right now and I said Brian and Peter
[Music]
rates on Brian
yet one more date everybody Oh God again
there's no question about Brian I just
want to focus on Brian
that's all we're a gang pulled from this
date Ryan loves her I love you I love
with you and I want to be ready forever
he loves her so much
now I'm going to want to live with peace
so this it's different it's different
vibe it's a different more heartbreaking
soul wrenching body gutting personality
depleting today I'm feeling insecure
love soul sucking and unsure know
everyone after watching this it was the
most captivating ten minutes of
television ever you live the game
married okay another time time fight me
on that the ending of a Sopranos the
finale of Breaking Bad
the I don't know any ID to fight me on
this the most captivating Penman
television in the history of time with
Peter Krause and Rachel Lindsay blasting
wondering wondering well wife so Peters
wearing green at first which like why
didn't your great Peter I mean don't
even recognize you
and he's like the feelings of doubt are
still there but these feelings are so
recent Oh God and then we go to the
nighttime where we get the golden watch
Rachel is walking to see Peter and she
looks like she doesn't anyone like yes I
keep looking for clarity and I'm just
not getting it but she gets there and
she's wearing grey and he's ring grey
and for the first time they acknowledged
that they are matching look at this look
at the matching we really are matching
it's so ironic because tonight will be
the night that they are not a match
anymore the goal tonight is to leave
knowing where she stands and for him to
know why fan guys are actually tearing
up now and I really cried watching this
I have never cried watching this show I
love this show but I have never cried
watching it until tonight yeah it gets
intense quickly and I'm gonna make one
joke before I get into the seriousness
of it there's more power Rachel's like
you tell me how serious you want to be
and you're like talking about the size
of our bed and dogs if there's one thing
but it is an indication that a
relationship is going to get serious if
you're talking about dogs
and the size of your bed what's that
discussion it can't be very long I'm too
tall for a queen I need a king okay is
there a lot of back and forth on that I
think so I'm in this because I want
someone who wants what I want I want
someone who wants to move towards
marriage basically Rachel's like I need
I don't understand if you are into me
and you want to be with me to see our
future together why can't you propose
and Peter's like I have one opportunity
to make sure that it's the right job has
one Mornington
she's like no you've done he's like I
choose that one opportunity and that is
my choice and then you think it's over
but Peter whoa
Peter backtrack remembers you you know
take terrific and he's like I care about
you so much that I will propose just to
show you that I care about it you would
do it completely out of finger doing it
for you
oh my god I did not see that coming
I thought Peter Krause was gonna stand
firm and make it up
things would end but no he really cared
about her he was like I would do it for
you to prove to you that I want to
pursue this relationship she's like no I
don't want to make you do it I don't
want to spend doing it as peer pressure
and like when she had kind of wanted to
do it me like I don't know you want from
you then we just have to split right
here now is that what you want no like
before you know it they are crying and
kissing and kissing and crying and their
tears are in their mouths and Rachel's
trying to walk away which is like a lot
of walk away leaders holding her arm cuz
he doesn't want her to walk away like a
literal hugging in fact the important
thing of their conversation and their
relationship and their likeable
compatible personalities that are also
so different
ah relationships in 2017 am i so
ultimately you know they break up
they're going up it's over and Peter is
like alone into the room I always
thought he said this to Rachel in the
promos but alone to the room he's like
ah oh it's here
Oh God
Oh and he said Stuart go find someone a
mediocre life with because I would have
given you an amazing life you would have
aah he puts her coat on four and he's
like I wish you the best
it's just there's so much it's so
painful and it was such a real real
breakup to watch it was so hard there's
an edge among 10 most captivating
minutes of television so again there
live for three hours because okay and
they cut the Peter like crouching by a
trunk of like stage equipment oh my god
what I cut away the producer was like I
was like Sam over here I don't know if
they have walkie-talkies
so then Peter is on stage with Rachel
and it is almost just as painful they
haven't seen each other since May but
Peter said he was just crying backstage
and Rachel seems so frustrated and
Rachel then I gotta say I love Rachel
but I think she was trying to make it
seem like she didn't care about Peter
maybe as much as the show was making her
seem as though she did she was like it
wasn't really about that you weren't
proposing it was more about something
else but it seems like it was about this
they wasn't moving and then I don't I
just don't think like this this world
this process this journey is the show I
just don't think like it's for you
Rachel tried to get a bachelor moment
uh-huh uh-huh I'd say what you're doing
Rachel Lindzi Rachel actually told me in
an interview that she didn't want any of
her top four guys to be the bachelor
shameless huh and we witnessed it live
on Monday night Rachel said I don't
think this show is for you like you need
more time you neither like see things
through to Peter please don't take him
from us Rachel I know it didn't work out
with you too but please don't take him
from the people do you guys remember on
their last date on the finale when he
said I'm picturing us I'm picturing us
going to the farmers market 20
with painting what man says that the
most perfect man wants to go to the
farmers market with you Rachel please
don't take him from us
she's like I don't think the shows for
you I think you need more time
having the format for you once with me
Rachel
onward and upward and things in now we
gotta take our emotions from down here
at a negative 72 to well up at a 10
because we've still got a proposal us
back through the happy nap Ryan and
Rachel Bryan both were posting but I
love you and she's like I love you oh I
forgot to mention something we to school
Peter she loves you guys anyway but she
doesn't care about I'm remind her she
and care and she told him live she said
oh he apologized for saying that she
would have a mediocre life with whoever
she picked and she was like yeah I'm
living my best life here's the ratio for
living her best life the Brian knows
what he wants
Rachel Pittman Lindsey
will you be my brain forever Mary honey
proposes rachel is so happy and they are
so happy on after the final rose and it
was quite a joy to watch because let's
all remember in exile and Vanessa
Grimaldi's after the final rose which
was a hit a word painful or maybe
another word text rates on Bryan rod
pence they were so cute all over each
other and of Bryan still oh so
interracial he was like what she would
think about a winter wedding and she's
like you know we're not brushing
anything like we just want to see like
build our lives together
pause okay this was interesting Chris
asked Rachel when did you know oh well
most people would say during hometowns
my hometown and I know about that
because she told Peter she loved it
laughing okay nothing to say about that
what an amazing season of The
Bachelorette you guys and oh my god
this summer on bachelor intern the
bachelor in paradise promo they gave us
a promo of bachelor parties which
premieres next Monday August 14th in
Tuesday August 15 on ABC and we will be
doing roses and Rose a about paradise
right here yes I drink wine once a week
now for work I'm okay with it so they
show this promo with the first page of
Korean tamari on the full incident dang
they're going there can't wait to watch
somebody Congrats to Rachel and Brian
truly I think Brian was a good guy and
he just showed Rachel how much he loved
her all season and rachel is a woman
again who knows what she wants and kept
it 100 all season she was an amazing
Bachelorette wishing them the best can't
wait to interview them both tomorrow and
it will be everything online and you
know what else is going up tomorrow my
reasons why Peter should be the bachelor
yeah I wrote an article about it journal
is a Pulitzer other journalism awards I
can't think of any others but please
give them to me for this listicle and
please let me know your thoughts I love
you guys so much thank you for being
here all season please make sure to LIKE
ETM Facebook subscribe to us on youtube
you can follow me on social media and we
can keep talking about this finale if
you want because it was truly
mind-boggling I do catch up late now bye
[Music]
so uh oh god is trying to send an email
to Peter just kidding I don't have his
email address let me get it for me